une réunion qui sommes informel pourtant
les capitales pour les marins pêcheurs
du boucle le giron de la société qui
drague le port de pêche du vauclin leur
explique qu'il va arrêter les travaux
pour des raisons financières
quand on a signé le marché du du port de
pêche de vos clés on avait 33 mille
mètres cubes de saab a retiré continue
là en ce moment en douane 30 minutes on
s'arrête un quart d'heure parce qu'il ya
des attitudes on s'arrête une heure on
s'arrête une heure parce que le bassin
et play et aya brea la dégradation on
n'a donc même pas 2 et par jour et bien
là on est en train de faire tourner en
juin les travaux n'avancent pas il ya
des choses il ya des choses qui se
disent qu'ils se font pas et ne sommes
pas autant faut toujours jean-monnet -
point de départ arthur très beau aurait
demandé à la ctm de revoir son contrat
la hausse pas de réponse et pour
comprendre ce qui se passe il nous
emmène sur un bassin de décantation la
boue draghi est déversée ici et l'eau
rejetée à la mer on n'arrive pas à les
rappeler assez rapidement parce qu'on a
des problèmes de d'être issus dans le
port beaucoup des sachets ménagers et on
a un problème de décantation ça dit que
quand il est rappelé il faut qu'on a une
pour qu'il se vide sadi condamne 30
minutes et en attend trois heures
démonstration la dragueuse se met en
marche dans le port de pêche à l'aubour
eu un arrêt dans le bassin et cinq
minutes plus tard
concours se bouger la tête à bouger
[Applaudissements]
direction la dragueuse elle est obstruée
par des déchets de toutes sortes
impossible pour cette entreprise de
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
le port de pêche du vauclin est tapissé
de détritus ils ne peuvent être craints
finalement les marais pêcheurs sont
furieux à marée basse
ils ne peuvent pas manoeuvrer mais ce
qu'on réclame c'est que vraiment qu'on
puisse soit nous indemnisé déjà parce
qu'on manque à gagner au lac de kucera a
payé on peut passer du ballon mais on va
payer le rôle on a beaucoup de choses à
bernabeu papier donc on l'aurait micro
chômeurs indemnisés lol en l'absence de
réponse de la 7e le giron de la société
qui grattent le corps va donc arrêter
les travaux
il est super 80% de son chiffre
d'affaires sur ce marché ici il poursuit
le dragage c'est la société qui risque
de couler